[Musique]
la french Tech est une initiative qui a
été lancée par le gouvernement il y a 10
ans maintenant par le Ministère de
l'économie en vue d'aider les startups
françaises d'être plus visibles à
l'échelle nationale mais également à
l'international et surtout de leur
permettre d'accélérer leur croissance
nous la fin de check Paris Saclay on
constitue un des réseaux de la French
tech et on couvre le territoire du 78 et
du 91
on a cette typologie de startup qui est
particulière qui sont les start-up
deeptech alors la dictée qu'est-ce que
c'est ce sont les startups qui ont un
lien très fort avec les laboratoires en
effet ce sont des structures qui ont
besoin de développer pendant des mois
voire des années leur solution pour
pouvoir adresser le marché nous le
territoire de Paris on concentre un
grand nombre de ces start-up plus de 70%
de ses 600 startups qui constituent le
territoire de Paris-Saclay
notre rôle aujourd'hui c'est d'aider ces
startups pour pouvoir accéder à des
financements adaptés également à des
structures et des bâtiments adaptés et
surtout de leur permettre de recruter
plus facilement des talents
est fière d'être devenu une capitale
French tech elle était jusqu'à lors une
communauté alors la force d'être une
capitale French tech c'est d'être au
plus proche du gouvernement et de
pouvoir adapter ou proposer des
solutions adaptées aux start-up de son
territoire la note rôle ça sera bien
entendu de permettre au gouvernement de
proposer des initiatives des programmes
des financements pour ces startups la
diptèques qui sont fortement reconnus
sur notre territoire Paris Saclay
[Musique]
en fait est une société qu'on a crée en
2014 sur 50 ans en Yvelines qui est
spécialisé dans les usages des
technologies immersives pour les
professionnels
en particulier commercialise depuis deux
ans maintenant un produit dédié aux
thérapeute spécialiste des troupes
cognitifs visuels et moteur produit qui
s'appelle Moover et qui obtient des
résultats vraiment impressionnants sur
le traitement de la dyslexie
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est évidemment plus
visible au niveau du ministère de
l'Industrie et on a des visites
ministérielles maintenant et on met en
avant les startups sur des thématiques
identifiées ce qu'on a fait déjà le 16
février avec le ministre de l'Industrie
[Musique]